et la dévotion.
Cela fait référence à une transformation positive
à travers l'apprentissage, la sagesse et la commémoration de Dieu.
Le mot « djihad » signifie tout cela en même temps.
Parfois, le djihad peut prendre la forme d'un combat,
mais seulement parfois,
selon des conditions strictes,
selon des règles et des limites.
Dans l'islam,
le bénéfice d'un acte doit dépasser le tort ou la souffrance qu'il entraîne.
De surcroit,
les vers du Coran qui sont liés au djihad ou au combat
n'annulent pas les vers évoquant le pardon,
la bienveillance
ou la patience.
Mais je crois maintenant qu'il n'y a aucune circonstance sur Terre
qui excuse le djihad violent,
car cela mènera à plus de souffrance.
Mais l'idée du djihad a été détournée.
Elle a été pervertie pour signifier une lutte violente,
là où les musulmans traversent des moments difficiles,
et transformée en terrorisme
par des islamistes fascistes comme Al-Qaïda,
l’État Islamique et d'autres.
Mais j'en suis venu à comprendre
que le vrai djihad signifie faire tout son possible
afin de renforcer et de vivre les qualités que Dieu aime :
l'honnêteté, la loyauté,
la compassion, la bienveillance,
la fiabilité, le respect,
la sincérité --
des valeurs humaines que partagent nombre d'entre nous.
Je suis né au Bangladesh
mais j'ai grandi surtout en Angleterre.
C'est ici que je suis allé à l'école.
Mon père était un universitaire
et nous étions là du fait de son travail.
En 1971, nous étions au Bangladesh quand tout a changé.
La Guerre d'indépendance nous a terriblement touchés,
montant famille contre famille,
voisin contre voisin.
A l'âge de 12 ans, j'ai vécu la guerre,
la pauvreté dans ma famille,
la mort horrible de 22 membres de ma famille
ainsi que le meurtre de mon frère aîné.
J'ai été témoin de meurtres...
d'animaux se nourrissant de cadavres dans la rue,
la famine partout autour de moi,
la sauvagerie, une violence atroce --
une violence insensée.
J'étais un jeune homme,
un adolescent, fasciné par les idées.
Je voulais apprendre
mais durant 4 ans, je n'ai pas pu aller à l'école.
Après la Guerre d'indépendance,
mon père a été emprisonné pendant deux ans et demi,
j'allais le voir en prison toutes les semaines
j'apprenais seul à la maison.
Mon père a été relâché en 1973
et il a fui en Angleterre en tant que réfugié
puis nous l'avons suivi.
J'avais 17 ans.
Ces expériences m'ont rendu
pleinement conscient des atrocités et des injustices du monde.
Et j'avais un fort désir --
un désir très vif et profond --
de réparer les erreurs
et d'aider les victimes de l'oppression.
Pendant mes études en faculté au Royaume-Uni,
j'ai rencontré des personnes
qui m'ont montré comment canaliser ce désir
et aider via ma religion.
J'ai été radicalisé --
assez pour considérer la violence comme correcte,
voire une vertu, en certaines circonstances.
Je me suis impliqué dans le djihad en Afghanistan.
Je voulais protéger la population musulmane afghane de l'armée soviétique.
Je pensais que c'était cela le djihad :
mon devoir sacré
qui serait récompensé par Dieu.
Je suis devenu prêcheur.
J'étais l'un des pionniers du djihad violent au Royaume-Uni.
Je recrutais,
je levais des fonds, j'entraînais.
J'ai confondu le vrai djihad
et cette perversion présentée par les islamistes fascistes --
ces gens qui utilisent l'idée du djihad
pour justifier leur désir de pouvoir, d'autorité et de contrôle sur Terre :
une perversion perpétuée aujourd'hui par les groupes islamistes fascistes
comme Al-Qaïda, l’État Islamique et d'autres.
Pendant environ 15 ans,
je me suis battu durant de courtes périodes
au Cachemire et en Birmanie,
en plus de l'Afghanistan.
Notre objectif était de supprimer les envahisseurs,
de soulager les victimes oppressées
et, bien sûr, d'établir un état islamique,
un califat pour le règne de Dieu.
Je l'ai fait ouvertement.
Je n'ai enfreint aucune loi.
J'étais fier et reconnaissant d'être britannique --
je le suis toujours.
Je n'éprouvais aucune hostilité envers ceci, mon pays,
ni d'hostilité envers les citoyens non-musulmans
et c'est toujours vrai.
Durant un combat en Afghanistan,
certains Britanniques et moi avons créé un lien spécial
avec un garçon afghan de 15 ans,
Abdullah,
un gamin innocent, aimant et adorable,
qui voulait toujours faire plaisir.
Il était pauvre.
Les garçons comme lui faisaient les corvées dans le camp.
Il semblait assez heureux
mais je me demandais --
il devait beaucoup manquer à ses parents.
Ils avaient dû rêver d'un meilleur futur pour lui.
Une victime de circonstances, prise dans la guerre,
cruellement imposée
par les cruelles circonstances de l'époque.
Un jour j'ai ramassé un obus de mortier n'ayant pas explosé dans une tranchée
et je l'ai fait déposer dans un labo situé dans une butte en terre de fortune.
Et je suis parti pour une escarmouche futile --
toujours futile --
et, à mon retour quelques heures après, j'ai découvert qu'il était mort.
Il avait essayé de récupérer les explosifs de cet obus.
Celui-ci avait explosé, et il est mort de mort violente,
déchiqueté par le même dispositif qui avait été inoffensif pour moi.
Je me suis alors posé des questions.
En quoi sa mort servait-elle un but ?
Pourquoi est-il mort et ai-je survécu ?
J'ai continué.
J'ai combattu au Cachemire.
J'ai recruté pour les Philippines,
la Bosnie et la Tchétchénie.
Les interrogations grandissaient.
Plus tard, en Birmanie,
j'ai croisé des combattants rohingyas,
qui étaient à peine adolescents,
nés et élevés dans la jungle,
portant des mitrailleuses, des lance-grenades.
J'ai rencontré deux garçons de 13 ans qui avec de bonnes manières et une voix douce.
En me voyant,
ils m'ont supplié de les amener en Angleterre.
Ils voulaient simplement aller à l'école -
c'était leur rêve.
Ma famille --
mes enfants du même âge --
vivaient dans une maison au Royaume-Uni,
allant à l'école
vivant une vie sûre.
Et je me demandais
combien de temps ces jeunes garçons avaient passé à se parler
de leurs rêves d'une telle vie.
Victimes des circonstances :
ces deux jeunes garçons,
dormant à même le sol, levant les yeux vers les étoiles,
cyniquement exploités par leurs meneurs
pour leur désir personnel de gloire et de pouvoir.
Peu après, j'étais témoin de garçons comme eux s'entre-tuant
dans des conflits entre groupes rivaux.
C'était partout pareil...
Afghanistan, Cachemire, Birmanie,
Philippines, Tchétchénie ;
de petits chefs de guerres incitaient des jeunes, vulnérables, à s'entre-tuer
au nom du djihad.
Musulmans contre musulmans.
Ne protégeant personne contre les envahisseurs ou les occupants ;
ne soulageant pas les oppressés.
Des enfants utilisés,
cyniquement exploités ;
des gens mourant dans des conflits
que je supportais au nom du djihad.
Cela continue encore aujourd'hui.
Réaliser que le djihad violent
dans lequel je m'étais engagé à l'étranger
était si différent --
il y avait un si grand gouffre entre mon expérience
et ce que je pensais du devoir sacré --
j'ai dû réfléchir à mes activités au Royaume-Uni.
Je devais considérer ma prédication,
mon recrutement, mes collectes,
mon entraînement
mais, surtout, ma radicalisation --
envoyer des jeunes gens à se battre et mourir
comme je le faisais --
tout cela était vraiment mauvais.
Je me suis impliqué dans le djihad violent au milieu des années 80,
commençant avec l'Afghanistan.
Quand j'en ai eu terminé, nous étions en 2000.
J'étais complètement immergé.
Tout autour de moi, les gens encourageaient,
applaudissaient
et même célébraient ce que je faisais en leur nom.
Mais, lorsque j'en suis sorti,
complètement désillusionné, en 2000,
15 ans avaient passé.
Qu'est-ce qui a mal tourné ?
Nous étions si occupés à parler de vertu
et nous étions aveuglés par une cause.
Et nous n'avons pas fait l'effort de développer un caractère vertueux.
Nous nous sommes dit que nous nous battions pour les oppressés
mais ces guerres ne pouvaient pas être gagnées.
Nous sommes devenu l'instrument même qui causa plus de morts,
complices de causer plus de misère
pour le bénéfice égoïste de quelques personnes cruelles.
Donc avec le temps,
beaucoup de temps,
j'ai ouvert les yeux.
J'ai commencé à oser
faire face à la vérité,
à réfléchir,
à faire face aux questions difficiles.
J'ai pris contact avec mon âme.
Qu'ai-je appris ?
Que les gens qui s'engagent dans le djihadisme violent,
les gens qui sont attirés par ce genre d’extrémismes
ne sont pas différents des autres.
Mais je crois que ces personnes peuvent changer.
Elles peuvent reconquérir leur cœur et le restaurer
en le remplissant de valeurs humaines qui guérissent.
Quand nous ignorons les réalités,
nous découvrons que nous acceptons ce qui nous est dit
sans y réfléchir de façon critique.
Nous ignorons les cadeaux et avantages que nombre d'entre nous chériraient
ne serait-ce qu'un instant dans leur vie.
J'ai mené des activités que je croyais correctes.
Mais j'ai maintenant commencé à remettre en question
comment je savais ce que je savais.
J'ai sans cesse dit aux autres d'accepter la vérité
mais je n'ai pas donné au doute la place qu'il méritait.
Cette conviction que les gens peuvent changer
prend racine dans mon expérience,
mon propre voyage.
En lisant beaucoup,
en réfléchissant,
en méditant et en apprenant à me connaitre,
j'ai découvert, j'ai réalisé
que le monde islamiste du « nous et eux » est faux et injuste.
En considérant les incertitudes dans ce que nous affirmions,
ces vérités inviolables,
ces vérités incontestables,
j'ai développé une compréhension plus nuancée.
J'ai réalisé que dans un monde plein de variation et de contradiction,
les prêcheurs insensés,
seuls les prêcheurs insensés comme je l'ai été,
ne voient aucun paradoxe aux mythes et fictions
qu'ils utilisent pour affirmer l'authenticité.
J'ai compris l'importance vitale de la connaissance de soi,
de la conscience politique
et du besoin d'une compréhension profonde et étendue
de nos engagements et nos actions,
comment cela affecte les autres.
Aujourd'hui je vous appelle tous,
en particuliers ceux qui croient sincèrement au djihadisme islamiste,
à refuser l'autorité dogmatique,
renoncez à votre colère, votre haine et votre violence ;
apprenez à réparer les erreurs
sans même tenter de justifier un comportement cruel, injuste et futile.
Au lieu de cela, créez quelques choses belles et utiles
qui nous survivront.
Approchez le monde, la vie,
avec amour.
Apprenez à développer
ou à cultiver votre cœur
pour voir la bonté, la beauté et la vérité chez les autres et dans le monde.
Ainsi nous comptons plus pour nous-mêmes...
pour les autres,
pour nos communautés
et, pour moi, pour Dieu.
C'est le djihad --
mon vrai djihad.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)